to the afternoon session
so we agreed with Jacob that during the
talk
the speaker will repeat the question so
we don't have to run with the microphone
during the Q a we'll give you the
microphone in case you want to do a
speech or something
okay so
let's keep it short in any case
so our first speaker in the afternoon is
Mark vinyls he's going to tell us about
the theoretical limits of one uip
learning
things are worth so yeah I'll be talking
not only about that but in general so
connections between proof complexity and
touch solvers so what can prove
complexity tell about tax rollers so
let's start with something we all know
the DPL algorithms
this uh simple backtracking algorithm
where we start uh guessing an assignment
to variables
we Branch if at on some point we reach
some conflict that means a clause that
is not that is falsified by our
assignment then we backtrack
and if we find that at some point some
value should be forced
because one cross is unit and we need to
set that value to propagate then we unit
propagate and we cut some part of the
search straight
so that's uh dpll and if since it's a
backtracking algorithm we can think of
its search tree right which is just
all the branches variables would go
through
and yeah this is uh the first three that
would correspond to this formula so we
would start Maybe by branching on X then
on y then when we get the Z we would
have a conflict we would backtrack and
keep exploring all the branches
and because this formula isn't
satisfiable
uh will eventually explore all the
possible search three
and find out that no there's no solution
here
now
um very useful tool to analyze dtll is
proof complexity so the resolution
process
resolution is just saying that we can
take two Clauses any two Clauses from
our original formula and if they have a
variable with different settings we can
result them together
and now if we look at the search tree
we reverse the arrows so from upside
down to bottom up Suddenly we have a
resolution proof
so that makes us happy because now if we
have
lower bonds for resolution we get BPL
lower ones
or in other words if we know that the
formula has a can be solved efficiently
with the PLL then that's because a short
resolution proof exists
that DPL then let's move forward in time
and talk about cdcl
which is as you all know this version of
the pillar where we can be a bit smarter
with our conflicts and instead of just
backtrack we can go and learn some
Clause from our conflict
and hopefully we'll learn something that
will be usable in the future
so if we look at this formula and this
search tree when we move down here to
Forex and we were trying to figure out
oh is is it possible to assign that to
some value it would go here say no
that's not possible here that that's not
possible either
it tells us that it's not a good idea to
set both X to Zero and Y to zero because
it will reach a conflict
but well the conflict it's between these
two Clauses and there's no X variable
here so this tells us that the conflict
is not because of x x has nothing to do
about that so we can learn something
smarter than it's not a good idea to set
X and Y to zero you can learn in the
battery set y to zero so we can go and
record that and say yeah y must be set
to one
and then we when we backtrack
eventually set X to one
and we try to figure out what the right
value of y should be then it will
already we already know that it's
supposed to be one so we'll cut half of
the or part of the research three
and our
our composition will be faster
so now because we are remembering
Clauses we're learning Clauses our state
before was just the personal assignment
now we have both a partial assignment
and some learn clauses
and then there's a
detail that will be useful in the future
that now it might be useful to forget
part of the of the state so that's
something that doesn't make much sense
with the parallel but with cdcl maybe
sometimes we'll want to forget what our
partial assignment was and that's what
we call a restart
or we might want to forget some of the
courses that we learned
and that's what I'll call forget
then can we analyze cdcl the same way
that uh with it with TPL with resolution
yes we can still do that and the
technique is exactly the same we just
take this search straight flip the
errors upside down
and now because we are using learn
clauses
so this is part of the first three that
we cut off so now this is not going to
come from one of our original Clauses
instead it's going to come from one of
the Clauses that we learned before
but it's still resolution not much
changes here
well
actually something does change which is
that before we had a proof that looked
like a tree
and now we have these Clauses that being
re that are being reused so we're going
to some
other more general form of resolution
so let's summarize what I said just now
so we have that CCL produces proves that
are in resolution form and we can use
the that to prove lower bounds on the
runtime of cbcl
uh I also mentioned that proofs in DPL
are not general resolution they these
are proofs that look like a tree and in
fact we know from the proof complexity
literature that uh tree-like and general
resolution proofs can be very different
so true like proofs can be exponentially
larger than uh general resolution probes
so then that gives us one reason for why
BPL is cdcl is uh better than DPL
which is that it produces drug-like
proof instead of just three like proofs
but of course well DPL was limited maybe
ctsel is also limited by some other
restriction right could be that it's
more General than BPL but it's still
restricted to some other processor
and this is a question that was
investigated soon after cdcl was
proposed
and a fairly good answer came in the
late 2000s showing that under a fairly
natural model of ctcl
we can show that
CCL can do everything that resolution
can
so let's be a bit more precise about
that actually there's a couple of
theorems
saying this that that cdcl can simulate
resolution
so
one is with non-deterministic variable
decisions that means that
we're now taking our cdcl server and we
are
since cheating in that where we have an
oracle that every kind that CCL should
branch in a variable it's going to tell
yeah that's a good variable to branch on
so places that
so instead of saying that
CSL can find resolution proofs I'll say
can reproduce resolution proofs because
we have to tell the solver what the
proof is before we can find it
yeah what the result said that says then
is that if you have this optimal
variable decisions
then if you have a resolution proof of
some length L then cdcl will be able to
reproduce that proof with a small
overhead and will talk more about that
later Mark yeah shouldn't there be
restarts as well there's going to be
restart I'll mentioned
and then there's another version of the
result which
is well instead of having
non-determinism having an oracle let's
try having a solver that just throws
random coins whenever it has the branch
and then what happens is that we can
still simulate the resolution but now
it's a special kind of resolution called
bounded width resolution
meaning that the longest clause in your
proof should be small so if the longest
proof in your Clause has at most 10
literals then cdcl will do that with
time n to the 10 plus I mean a bit more
than into the 10 but something like that
and let's then see how does one proof
this these results are I won't go into
details but just an idea
why is it not already solved why is
seems to be completely solved but it's
completely solved as long as you assume
that this is the right model of CTL
then you could think well
in practice of course initial is not
going to make this uh it's not going to
have an oracle to give it what variables
to branch on but it's not deterministic
it's going to branch
true yeah so if we assume this then
there's not that anything we have to say
it but if we want a model that captures
reality then we want to work with a more
fine model
I don't understand the model how it can
be different resolution is not
cdcl is an algorithm of course it cannot
of course otherwise so otherwise we
would be automating yes
right so I completely agree with that
so how can you improve this
you can improve this by
not that you can improve on this
statement but things that you could
improve for instance are the overhead or
you try to try to find out which
assumptions are really necessary
so and but yeah I will actually talk
more about that too
let's continue I think
but I mean this is like no you could
improve on this in different way this is
like very much stronger than this is an
extremely strong complement to
non-automatibility right on the other
hand you know on the one hand you know
you can't automate but this says you can
almost ultimate you can take this
extremely super super concrete coated up
algorithm and you only remove the
variable decisions you need like
everything else as is
and now you're actually automating
and now you can ask this for like you
know maybe I could plug in a you know
variable State and dependent some Decay
decision scheme but something I don't
know do something to the variable
deletion of the cloth deletion or
something and maybe I'm again ultimately
so you can play this game with different
heuristics components in your cdcl
solver and try to pin down like where is
the entry hardness
okay so on that as well so what is the
difficulty of actually pinning down a
decision heuristic
and
um getting to try to approve from this
the title results
what's the question what happens when we
fix a message issue if you say instead
of this non-deterministic you
orthogonalized branching right and say
okay any branching but if you just say I
have this fantastic branching heuristic
right and include that in your uh in
your analysis why is that difficult I'll
answer this in uh three sites okay but
the yeah but turns out then you kind of
okay
good so
uh let's then yeah see quickly how uh
how do we do this
so the idea is that we have a resolution
proof we would like to simulate that
with CCL so the most natural thing that
you would do is try to learn every
clause in the proof that makes a lot of
sense
so how would you do this with the cdcl
algorithm
you would try to falsify a clause the
Clause that you want to learn hopefully
you'll get the conflict and learn that
clause
so if that happens great
and well while this is a great idea it
doesn't work but still it can be patched
because we don't really need to learn
every clause
everything that we need to do is to fool
the solver to think that it has learner
Clause so if the if every time that the
solver would make a propagation because
of this learn Clause it still happens
because of some other clauses and every
time that there's a conflict it still
happens then the solver won't notice
whether it has learned that close or not
so okay fair enough then
we can use that idea which is really the
key behind those two results
and instead of learning Clauses we just
act as well as if we had learned them
and then we have a simulation of uh
resolution by ctcl
now well we were talking about the model
which assumptions do we need to make for
this algorithm to work
well there they are the following so
first we need to assume that the solver
is making optimal choices
because every time that we have to
branch
what we do is pick one of the literals
from the close we want to learn
and set it to force so here we we really
need to know what the proof is what
proof or who trying to reproduce and we
need to make these choices
then another assumption is that we're
not throwing any Clauses away
and another one is that we're restarting
fairly frequently actually here I'm
sitting a bit because I'm restarting
immediately after learning but
it's not important
and we're after assuming that we do some
standard learning so that when you learn
a course that's the Clause that related
to your conflict if you learn a clause
that has nothing to do with your
conflict then that's not really cdcl
yeah then uh let me answer your question
Karim uh what happens when we fixed so
instead of having these optimal variable
choices we fix branching
so the first thing to observe is that
we really need optimal variable choices
because otherwise we would be
contradicting some resulting Theory
saying that if some algorithm some
deterministic algorithm could simulate
resolution so find a short resolution
proofs then P would be equal to NP but
then that's something that alert and
more exproed a few years back
so we really think that we need that
assumption
but well maybe we can still try to play
with a specific decision heuristics see
what happens then
yeah and then there are some results in
in this direction uh for instance if you
have a static order so
you have a variable order that doesn't
change at any point during solving
then
there are some formulas where that does
exponentially worse than resolution so
the formulas that have short proofs but
cannot be done with a static order
or if you choose visits or anything
that's conflict driven branching
then there's also going to be some
formulas where they have short relation
proofs but because of this branching
heuristic the solver will run in
exponential time
now
one drawback about this is that the
formulas are fairly contrived it's not
something you'll see in practice
but
um
you could still try to design a
heuristic that will not be affected by
that and see what happens in practice
and uh turns out that there are some
instances where
some modifications of visits can work
better and you have to ask Vijay if you
want to know more about that
good so that was branching
now I also mentioned that this
simulation uh
is an efficiency Connection in the sense
that if you have a proof of length l in
resolution
you'll get the cdcl proof in what n to
the fourth times L steps so polynomial
can be improved to cubic
and now that's something that I'm happy
with it's a polynomial I'm happy but if
you're building a solver that runs in
linear time then you are not happy
that's that's too much
so can we improve this simulation
overhead or maybe
it's it really it's really needed we we
need some overhead
and here again turns out that
there is some overhead that's needed
when you when you use cdcl so now let's
think of a model of CCL where really it
can do anything that that you want so do
you want optimal variable choices you've
gotten do you want to restart whenever
you want sure
um so just give all the tools that the
sort of might have might have it's of
course going to be able to polynomial
simulate resolution because it's so the
best separation that we could hope for
is a polynomial
but still there is uh there are some
formulas that have linear proofs in the
real resolution yet require
uh
quadratic proofs in cdcl
right uh so how would one go and prove
that well the basic idea is that the
kind of Clauses that cdcl learns have
some syntactical restrictions so we can
build a proof system that incorporates
those restrictions and then prove a
separation between these uh restricted
version of resolution and normal
resolution
so again to give a flavor of how that
can be done
when cdcl learns across that's conflict
analysis it will start with the conflict
Clause then you do take a reason cross
and resolve them then it will take
another reason cross resolve them and so
on so learning across will look like
this uh input resolution sequence of
derivations
until we read some course that can be
learned and reused later
the question was does the learn length
of the proof include all the Matrix or
just number of steps uh this is length
so only number of steps
so the total size could be larger
prove that since your produce will look
like this this sequence of derivations
then there will be some limit that we
can remember and maybe using the feature
but so far this is no restriction so a
normal resolution proof can also look
like dust like that just I mean you can
have trees that have just
um height one and then this will be
exactly the same as resolution
so what makes a difference is to say
let's impose some conditions on what
this learned Clauses this levels can be
one very natural restriction which would
be to say that everything that I learned
that I learned must be one empowering so
that's the converse of observed meaning
that
if a solver learns a clause then it does
so because it can it enables the solver
to the more unit propagations in the
future otherwise it's a redundant close
there's no no need to learn it
so that's very natural but it's also a
very annoying procession to work with
so instead of that
um there's a similar restriction that we
can do and is to ask all lemmas to be
merges
so emerge is a resolution step where we
have two closest sharing uh literal in
addition to a variable with opposite
sense and then this letter will get
merged when they are getting resolved
so that's that's what happens and turns
out that merges and one empowering
Clauses are fairly related so it's it's
not
it really makes sense to to ask for this
if you work with a learning scheme like
first uip then you get exactly this
restriction
and by doing some modifications you can
actually also capture other learning
scenes but I won't go into the text
your how do you go are you going to get
the empty Clause well uh
so the the the very last
um sequence doesn't have this
restriction
so just to summarize to summarize what
they what they said we can have this Pro
System let's call it merge resolution
because it builds on some per system
from the sixes
that were yeah we ask uh learn Clauses
to be merges
and that's what we what we do then so we
can show that see the kind of proofs
that cdcl produces will always be in
this form
and
we can show that
there's a separation between normal
Revolution and nerves resolution
that was the result so now where do we
go from here
um
just take on this topic of overhead
right we explained one linear factor in
the overhead but the overhead was cubic
so what about the other N squared Factor
can we explain that can we remove it
um what can we do there
and
if I take a proof in this
restricted merge resolution Pro system
and give it to a cdcl solver will it do
better than if it only had the
resolution proof system
and maybe similarly to what happened
with branching where
we expose limitations and then you put
design
branching scheme that avoids those
problems
is there a way to do learning that
avoids this this kind of problems
and then staying still
um with the cdcl versus Revolution topic
I mentioned a few assumptions and
quickly discussed branching but there
were a few more assumptions that we had
to make for instance that no Clauses are
ever being deleted
and the solver restarts frequently there
has been work
in both these questions but uh I'd say
that the
there's much more we would like to know
and then well
let's leave resolution behind and think
longer term
it uh resolution is great for capturing
cdcl but solvers nowadays do more things
than this yet they do pre-processing
they do they reason with our team so the
volume constraints they do symmetry
breaking
so what can proof complexity say about
all these things
unfortunately it can say things about uh
party and civilian constraints there are
proof systems
can deal with this kind of constraints
but pre-processing symmetry breaking
they're just too strong so the proof
systems that we have
that can capture these techniques we
cannot say anything meaningful about
them
so that's very annoying and it's not
there if we can do anything so can we
Define pro systems that are more
tailored to what solvers are doing
practice and then say things about them
that will be great
yeah so the question is
we can model things that solvers do like
pre-processing and symmetry breaking
using very strong strong proof systems
such as extended frigate
but we can't say anything meaningful
about this
so quickly Define then a subsystem of
extended fragrance that can still
capture maybe not all but some of these
techniques and
um
and where we can prove lower ones
it's something like this has this has
been done by Sam and nil for instance so
there is work in this direction
things are happening
and then maybe we there are some
questions where maybe proof complexity
will not be the right right tool so
what can we say about satisfiable
formulas can proof complexity say
something about them maybe maybe not
fairly agnostic about this or the
question when is it easily efficient
proof complexity will be able to answer
or tell you some reasons for when cdcl
is efficient if you if there is a short
proof then maybe it can be found but
uh
not that there exists the proof we've
seen that doesn't mean that citizer can
find it so then what are the properties
of formulas
this is a very very hard question
we don't expect to find a close answer
to this but is there anything we can say
I mean again there's
measures like through width
that can answer this question in
practice in series or but not so much in
practice
there's measures from the practice side
that um
in cell correlations but don't mean
multi-theory
so what can we say over there
and that's it for me thank you
any questions from Mark
so about your last previous slide
so um satisfiable formulas for instance
there are these results about
knowledge and all yes
[Music]
so
yeah another thing is pre-processing and
symmetry breaking I mean there are these
parity and pseudo Boolean constraints
there's a lot of
weak supposedly weak proof systems that
model these in some sense no
is basically efficient effective
simulation and maybe resolution
parity and constraints just wrestling or
something
things like party into the Boolean we
can handle but it's more of the yeah
replacing and symmetry rating that we
are more lost
okay
okay so these are open problems
what about when a CDS cdcl is not
efficient
I mean is there something Beyond cdcl
that we got stuck you know for the past
you know three two and a half decades
kind of just doing this is there
something else that we can look at
yeah
[Music]
but you see what I'm saying I mean I'm
just curious as to why are we in this
and why does this work and is there no
way to answer that question
no it's a great question and there are
some things like civil game solvers
there's uh sdcl yeah yeah so so you need
to go to other kind of uh and that goes
to my point in the morning which is if
we're solving a real problem right which
is coming from somebody's head maybe a
CNF encoding for it may not be the right
way to kind of Reason about it and we
need to go to these other things that
describe it more naturally I think
you're right
yeah I'm not saying anything weird I
could just say you know we focus on
difficult problems in CNF when in fact
uh you know let's move on
you mentioned that um
if you have if your visits uh uh
it was exponentially worse than in
resolution I'm just wondering if you
have any lower bounds if you don't have
anything you don't even have resids
whether it be double exponential
it might not it might not make sense but
but I mean to me the uh the activity
scores uh keeps you from it keeps you
focusing on on part of the problem
instead of instead of trying to solve
100 problems at once
and and so I was just wondering if
there's any lower bounds on on what and
what's be since the
I would think that uh
even worst case if you're doing BPL you
wouldn't do worse than exponential
but uh
yeah you shouldn't do version expansion
yes
so these results that you mentioned are
about worst case complexity today there
exists formula for which is a linear
resolution but uh so do we know anything
about average case
challenge if I may add their how do you
define knowledge yeah I know but what
I'm saying is looking at the worst case
of course has its benefits but it also
completely you know turns a blind eye
towards Maybe
what's happening in practice
yeah now vijay's point is is that uh I
don't know a good way to define an
average case
if we think of average case that would
be random formulas those are hard
periods so they're not very interesting
uh if we would like to say industrial
instances great but we don't know how do
we find them so
it's more of a definition problem I
think
okay let's thank Mark again
[Applause]
foreign